hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in ethics books
Aristotle engages in a very important
discussion that bears upon truth
distinguishing between what we've got up
here is truth in plot and in action or
if you want to call it truth insofar as
it's a matter of theory or speculation
which would also include a good degree
of communication in a truth insofar as
we apply it to the sphere of choice
action practical matters which is really
a concern for as Aristotle says the
practical part of the intellect but also
for other parts of the human being as
well and truth is a very important topic
not only for philosophy but for ethics
in general Aristotle discusses it you
have multiple points another place in
the nick of mechanics that we've done
another video on is the virtue of
truthfulness and that's in book in book
4 we're going to try to push that off
and then concentrate just on the upshot
of this and we're drawing from some very
short passages in which Aristotle
outlines something like a gem
theory of truth if you want to go
further into this too by the way you
would also want to look at the on the
soul where he discusses these topics in
similar ways as well so Aristotle says
that both parts of the rational part of
the human soul the part that's concerned
with da Noya the intellectual or or you
know reasoning part are concerned with
truth and the term truth there is a
Letha it's the same term that he uses
running throughout his work for for
truthful you know being in accordance
with truth and he says that the
intellectual virtues so we're talking
here about wisdom about intellect or
news about scientific knowledge but also
about craft technique and from Asus our
ways of attaining truth now when we
normally think about truth we typically
associated with what's called the
correspondence theory of truth and this
does in fact hold for much of
Aristotle's treatment correspondence
theory of truth in in essence says that
a statement is what is true or a thought
is what is true when it conforms to the
way things actually are when there's as
Thomas Aquinas will put it out much
later an an equation between intellect
and and reality Aristotle does in fact
hold a conception of truth like that for
theoretical matters and so if I say for
example this book is is very thick and
it's kind of peach ish and color
somewhere in between pink and orange
that's a correct statement about
something in the world now something
like that could of course change if I
color in the book and make it black then
perhaps it's no longer true
and we're not going to worry too much
about those sort of ramifications
because what we're really interested in
here is well why does Aristotle talking
about truth in terms of ethics well one
thing we might say is ethics is supposed
to be some sort of discipline that tells
us about what's right and wrong and you
know in Aristotle sense about what the
good life is what happiness consists in
so perhaps we can understand Penix
as a whole body of propositions that
then we could say are either true or not
true it's not entirely clear how you
know statements of ethics would conform
to some sort of outside reality but
that's a that's a separate issue as well
because that's actually beside the point
the point here is that when we're
talking about truth within the practical
sphere we're actually talking about
something more than just affirmation
catharsis in grief and denial which is
sort of the stock-in-trade you might say
of truth within the speculative or
theoretical sphere you say that
something is the case you deny that
something is the case there's more to it
when it comes to the domain of the the
moral or the ethical so in practical
matters and this would include matters
not only you know directly concerned
with ethics but also really anything
that is concerned with production with
the sphere of matters that that you know
are changing whose principles sometimes
change practical matters Aristotle talks
about four things in particular these
are very closely related he says that in
the sphere desire what corresponds to
affirmation and denial is actually
pursuit and avoidance designer here is
translating the term or Raxus which
means effectivity as well so think about
thing that involves our moods our
feelings our desires our orientations of
value towards one thing or another so
why is pursuit in avoidance analogous to
affirmation and denial well when you
think that something is in fact good
then you pursue it when you think that
something is in fact bad in a variety of
different ways then you try to avoid it
and we can go through long processes of
practical reasoning but they ultimately
Aristotle thanks conclude with well I
should go after that where I should stay
away from that could be an action could
be a person could be good or you know
some thing there's all sorts of
possibilities there this would also
include reasonings that involve us in
prioritizing as well I should pursue
this but not this well that means I
should pursue this so Aristotle thinks
that you know just as with affirmation
and denial those could be true or false
an affirmation can be true and it's true
when it affirms what is actually the
case a denial is is true when it affirms
what is actually the case not to do when
it affirms that what isn't the case
isn't the case right I've been a one way
to put it
things get a little tricky when we get
to negatives when we pursue something
that we really want to pursue
for instance happiness Aristotle thinks
that there is truth in that and it's
more than just the kind of truth that we
have in statement likewise when we avoid
things that we shouldn't avoid then
there's falsity in avoidance so if
taking medicine is something good for me
but I don't like to take medicine
because I don't like a doctor telling me
what to do bla bla bla bla bla I'm
actually false my actions my desires are
false in a certain respect Aristotle
thinks that this is very important to
understand for making sense of
that's particularly you've got this
other term here moral choice or proem
races we've done another core concept
video specifically on that Aristotle
thinks that that is or the juncture
point where all of this comes together
so what is truth then for the intellect
truth is for the theoretical it's like
truth is what we've just already said
that it is you know sort of a conformity
between the thought or the the
verbalization and the state of affairs
in terms of practical matters Aristotle
and stead is going to talk about
something a bit more complicated notice
that it's not so simple as just the
endpoint of desire or aversion turning a
you know pursuit or a version turning
towards something turning away from it
what we happen to feel this is where the
element of choice comes in truth needs
to be in agreement he says Oh Homer
logos at kusa holding itself in sort of
a structured way in relation to mapping
onto you might say right desire or
access orthos worth that rather feminine
in greek so desire and speculative truth
come together this is how you know if we
were to say ethics is perhaps a body of
propositions well that's fine but you're
not really grasping it until you put it
into practice and it's not just a matter
of doing the right actions
Aristotle's doesn't say truth in action
is you know agreement between for
speculative truth propositional truth
and right actions he says right desire
the person needs to be oriented the
right way effectively in terms of their
emotions in terms of their feelings in
terms of
what it is that they want and they don't
want this is why moral choice crisis is
so central to this era saw I didn't put
this on the board is going to call a
moral choice something that involves the
greed for that is is not without logos
which is argument or reasoning right and
desire he's also going to call choice a
sort of juncture point saying that it is
and it's very difficult to translate
this well so I'm just going to turn this
out there over access T an oft K or
noose erected coast which means
something like desire which is oriented
or inhabited by my mind or intellect or
reasoning and mind which is itself shot
through with desires as if we have these
two domains totally split off from each
other in choice they're coming together
so for choice to be good Aristotle tells
us the reasoning itself must be true the
reasoning about what's right or wrong
what's good or bad and the desire itself
must be right so he says that in order
for this really to take place we're
talking about habits we're talking about
hats ace and that's what the virtues are
so when we're thinking about truth in
the practical sphere laying the side you
know the truth save craft or something
along those lines we're talking about
moral concerns there's a lot more to it
than simply having some sort of
blueprint in terms of the set of
propositions that would consist in
ethics like a textbook and then just
acting that way the person has to be
rightly oriented in their effectivity
and the activity is not something
radically distinct from from the the
intellectual parts of them in fact
they're in
fused with each other so this is a very
challenging an interesting way of
looking at not only human nature but how
truth would fit into the entire of human
nature